[Music]  sir we've landed  are we still in all go we are go  we're dropping a secret team of robots  into a country that we're not supposed  to be in  it got serious the moment was thought up  hey sign up you're all gone well i'll  kill you  do it  these people have seen everything take  them all down no  do you have witnesses id on him yet  sending you a packet special forces huh  this guy is a deserter it could be the  ultimate field test yeah who's thinking  the same thing  she's a doctor they're all doctors  they're here in a good cause  come on man okay you're scaring her  you're scaring me i'm scared  find me like a man come on  you were made by humans to affect them  we're different i'm a man i have life  you're a machine  [Music]  you